one of the biggest fan theories out
there is that r plus l equals J raigarh
plus liana equals John which means that
jon snow isn't Ned Stark's bastard at
all but he is still a stark it's not
really made clear but lianna either runs
off with or gets kidnapped by Rhaegar
Targaryen Rhaegar you'll know as being
the son of the Mad King heiress and
older brother to Daenerys andrew sarris
this causes a bunch of problems not only
because Rhaegar is already married but
because Liana is actually betrothed to
Robert Baratheon this is kind of like
the big event that sparks off Robert's
rebellion you know when all the north
bands together to take on the south and
it's all sparked off by Liana and
Rhaegar Rhaegar ends up getting killed
by Robert at the battle of the Trident
and the Mad King eros ends up getting
stabbed in the back by the old
Kingslayer Jaime Lannister King's
Landing is completely sacked by the
north and just completely ruined
basically and after all that happened
Ned Stark takes a few of his friends try
and finally Anna and they track her down
to this weird place called the Tower of
joy which is this like weird lonely
Tower that Ray gars built for her by the
time they get there and Ned finds her
she's lying in a pool of her own blood
and she ends up dying we don't know what
she died of but it was probably
childbirth because if you think about it
when Ned Stark returns to Winterfell
he's got a baby in tow so it's not his
it's actually his sister's illegitimate
child who now kind of has a claim to the
throne so that's where r plus l equals J
comes from Ned Stark's been popping up
in some of the promo material for season
six like we've seen him in the Hall of
faces but also in the full-length
trailer we see what looks like Ned Stark
and a bunch of his friends go to an area
that kind of looks like where the Tower
of joy could be so this could be it this
could be our plus l equals J confirmed
we know that the right is a game of
thrones know who Jon Snow's mother is
george RR martin posed this question
stem way before filming and writing the
series ever started so they know they're
just not been telling us until now maybe
you